let's see what's on people's minds today
we will go to the phone lines at 6 1 7 8
3 0 47 50 and we will start today with
our caller from the 7 7 0 area code
caller from 7 7 0 what's your name where
are you calling from
7 7 0 I heard you shuffling hey Richard
what's going on hello yes what's going
on Richard ok again here I'm good hey so
here's my question I'm so with this
let's see senator Sanders somehow is
able to actually win the nomination
and does end up winning the presidential
race what do you think the odds are that
you will actually get a medicare-for-all
bill passed because it seems like even
those who do support Medicare for all
have some watered down version of it
like so how many do you think would
actually vote for it if it were to be
put put on them this is a very important
question which is that even within the
Democratic Party there is not sort of
unanimous consent around number one not
everybody in the Democratic Party
supports Medicare for all and even those
that support something that they call
Medicare for all they don't necessarily
support it in the exact way and
formulation that Bernie Sanders does but
I don't think that this is particularly
relevant because what we've seen is that
the more progressive position that you
start the negotiation from the better
off we will end up so Bernie Sanders
can't control whether Democrats take
control of the Senate in 2020 or 2022
Bernie Sanders can't at least not
directly control what the majority of
the Democratic majority is in the house
or whether they maintain one after the
midterm all he can do is say here's my
starting point and then he will
negotiate with whoever is there for the
most progressive possible plan so I
think you're bringing up a perfectly
reasonable question which is is it
guaranteed that a president Bernie gets
Medicare for all the answer is
definitely not definitely not and this
is just a reality I mean it's not a pro
or anti Bernie bias thing it's just
there's no guarantee that any pres
it gets done what they want to do the
more audacious it is the more difficult
it will be to do but we still want to be
starting from the best possible place
right I do have one more follow-up at
that time yes it's a quick question um
so one of the main arts like here
against Medicare for all courses how are
you gonna feed whatever someone brings
up Canada UK uh the number one from the
right source if you well but there you
know population is significantly less
that's why they're able to you know have
a system I guess he wasn't had a cure
for all at a state level instead of a
national level would actually be any
better
just because it would be a little easier
to manage or at least it's only a theory
so I dealt with this earlier this week
so I won't I won't do the full
explanation but so two things on that
number one I disagree with the premise
that if you have more people it's more
difficult to do because more people
actually means that the the risk pool is
larger and no one group within that
population is gonna throw off your
actuarial predictions nearly as much so
I reject that on principle that being
said I have no problem with Medicare for
all or other single-payer systems
starting at the state level I think that
from a pragmatic perspective you might
much more quickly be able to get
something done so I'm not opposed to it
in any way but the population argument
is a tired one that's a thank you all
right Richard yep gonna let you go thank
you for the call